foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
I will hold you
and protect you
so let love
warn you
sail the Moon
foreign
[Music]
by your side
close your tired I cannot wait
and soon
I'll see your smile
in Her Dream Baby
[Music]
don't worry
it's okay
I'll always be with you
[Music]
heart
party
[Music]
thank you
don't worry
it's okay
no one should have to suffer such loss
you know I meant it when I said I
understand how you feel but if you hold
on to the sadness it'll wave down
commit my cruiser
[Music]
start a new Journey
it wasn't the UCA that made the final
decision
it was APAC
private Corporation
so let love
warn you
till the morning
[Music]
[Applause]
PlayStation
[Music]
foreign
I don't understand
[Music]
[Applause]
his silence is
[Music]
you should see me in the crowd
what we've done that set in stone the
past is forever but the future even if
it has been written can be changed so
focus on the future not the past
to finish what he started
he wants to reclaim his Birthright
and rule over the planet with Genova at
his side
[Music]
I saw you lying there
I figured it was too late
wait what are you implying that I died
that I'm some kind of imposter
[Music]
you were here with me
five years ago
where are you
what happened to you
I'm trying so hard to find you
sorry feel like I failed you
[Music]
please
all right
[Music]
thank you
you are all powerful service dogs guys
on the goal and action puzzle levels of
story mode then make your own levels or
relative Play Levels created by other
users
the ultimate TV game
yeah
one more time
[Music]
available now
PlayStation
Once Dead
it's great to Army decimated by the
legions of a deer the demon god
but one light still flickers any
ever-growing Gloom the light of the dark
crusader
the radiance of monsters
[Music]
it is Darkness threatens to desolate our
world
ascends to Aureus my child
as His Holy Redeemer
in light we walk
burn
very Souls
[Music]
your flesh has been made sacrosanct with
the mark of the dark Crusaders
[Music]
thank you
great potential dwells within your
doubtless for you to be chosen firstly
[Music]
oh
prove yourself worthy of this gift
[Music]
by your Radiance grant me the strength
to continue to endure these dark days
[Music]
another unfortunate made a slave to
unceasing hunger
I pity you
recognize the Blessed beacons of
monstada and thwart ideas
[Music]
foreign
for as long as I can remember I have
looked for an equal
one who could push me
one who could surprise me
one who could even beat me
it's all I found
his disappointment
will one of you finally give me what I
desire
yes
we will
[Music]
be Upstream
everywhere
[Music]
living in the Darkness
the street
[Music]
it is time
to wake up
to a new reality
to a blank canvas that I have painted in
with warmth and peace
in my new era
choice is yours
whether to live in quiet serenity
or bloody strife
to dwell in joyous prosperity
or bitter rivalry
foreign
as sworn enemies
or United as brothers
[Music]
but our storm is brewing
and soon you will discover
that even in this new era
one constant remains
thank you
there is always something worth fighting
for
you have chosen to defy peace then you
have chosen war with a god
foreign
[Music]
we think there is an incredible
opportunity to make our platform games
and peripherals more accessible so that
even more people can enjoy the magic of
gaming we're just getting started with
our accessibility Journey with PS5 but
we're so excited about what we've been
able to do so far and our plans for the
future
thank you
game creator games
foreign
of either knowing someone with a
disability or a family member with a
disability and wanting them to be able
to participate with the PS5 and so it
was really us coming together to
ask ourselves what could we do based on
all the input we receive from the
community to be able to craft something
that really opened the doors we've
partnered with a lot of outside expert
consultants in this area charitable
organizations that help and advocate for
gamers with disabilities really helped
us understand what challenges we needed
to solve in order to provide a more
accessible controller that was more
customizable and more performative for
gamers with disabilities
foreign
[Music]
no matter who you are
some of the most inspiring things that
I've seen that have made me want to
think more about accessibility is seeing
the stories that players have and how
much it means to them when they're able
to sit down with the game for the first
time and play more than they ever
thought they could
some extent the principles behind
accessibility are a good Universal
Design principles
so thankfully we're able to think about
okay well if this information is only
available on screen well then it's not
accessible to a blind layer or if this
information is something you only hear
Joel there's a guy up on that second
floor right there it's not accessible to
a deaf player you know I think as
developers we we started with developing
accessibility features because we
realized that certain members of our
audience had special needs and certain
things would really block them I'm
excited for players to try various
features that we've created
from high contrast mode to traversal
assist
Auto pickup and navigation assist it
really depends on you and what you need
and that could be just a preference
maybe you have a temporary disability
maybe you have a permanent disability
maybe you can't see or you can't hear
I'm a game designer first and foremost
who's also legally blind I try and make
every game I make as accessible as
possible all sorts of people in the past
wanted to play our games and just could
they just had some limitation and didn't
allow them to play games
so it's really exciting that we all have
all sorts of limitations cannot jump
into part one and again seamlessly
transition into part two because they
share those same award-winning
accessibility features
[Music]
accessibility is important to
PlayStation to achie or Mission which is
to connect people to the power of play
where players of all abilities can share
the moments of joy
as she surveys the apartment her eyes
wander to Joel people who have
disabilities they're constrained by
Society in the way that we have designed
this world so having products that allow
them to experience the world
having accessibility built into our DNA
that's what is so important to me
but PlayStation 5 we built a brand new
voice platform which Powers
accessibility features like screen
reader chat transcription voice command
and voice dictation all these features
make PlayStation 5 more accessible
at the launch of PlayStation 5 we
introduced new functionality like Zoom
Bono audio support adding more language
support for screen reader and improving
the screen reader experience by
introducing functionalities like play
pause and repeat PlayStation 5 offers a
wide range of accessibility features
we are taking care of that architectural
layer of accessibility so the games can
focus on building even cooler
experiences
the biggest thing about the
accessibility features on the PS5 for me
and the thing that I want to make happen
is bringing people back into gaming we
are making this so you can have the same
experience and enjoy it like everybody
else and be a part of that excitement
there's still so much for us to discover
and do but we know that by listening to
the accessibility Community we can learn
how to make PS5 and Playstation as a
whole easier to jump into than ever
before for anyone who wants to play
[Music]
Christian song
while the original PlayStation VR was an
admirable first effort for Sony it was
also an awkward piece of Hardware it
launched when consumer Focus headsets
were in their nasancy which is probably
why Sony could get away with a
jerry-rigged chimera of old and new
technology psvr felt like a solution
hurriedly thrown together to make the
most of an emerging Trend its successor
the PlayStation VR2 is the opposite in
almost every way it's a thoughtfully
designed piece of Hardware that is
powerful and delivers a user-friendly
plug-and-play experience that is almost
entirely frictionless the technology
powering it is modern making it a worthy
companion to the PlayStation 5 and its
sense controllers are designed
specifically for gaming in VR spaces the
psvr2 is undoubtedly a major step
forward for PlayStation's virtual
reality Ambitions and it's one of the
best headsets on the market but in the
ever shifting landscape or virtual
reality its price and current value
proposition leave it in an awkward
position once again out of the box the
psvr2 looks and feels like a premium
piece of technology the matte white on
deep black PlayStation color scheme is
replicated here to great effect and the
form factor swaps the sharpness of the
PS5 for rounded corners and curved Bands
That Make the whole unit pleasing to
look at as well as put on and take off
the sense controllers are similarly
elegant in design comfortably filling my
hands and allowing my fingers and thumbs
to rest on the buttons and triggers very
naturally the original psvr was loaded
as being the most comfortable headset on
the market and psvr2 can also claim
their Accolade as it's even more
comfortable to wear it may feel a little
heavy for those who are used to the
lighter meta Quest too but the way it
feels well distributed so I didn't have
the neck fatigue issues that I feared
May crop up during longer sessions there
also some brilliant little product
design features in the psvr too that
when you hear about don't seem like a
big deal but make all the difference
when using the headset on a day-to-day
basis one such example is the headphones
that are included with the headset which
plug into the band and have a thin
plastic body that Contours around the
band so it doesn't even look like a
separate piece until the ends where a
small stretch of wire and inner
headphones Dangle on either side of the
band are too indents that you can push
their headphones into to safely hold
them in place like little finger traps
it's easy to put the headphones in take
them out and store them without ever
removing the headset this kind of care
and consideration put into Comfort
extends to the more essential parts of
the experience on the front of the
headset is a button that easily lets you
move the lenses towards and away from
the face another button on the back
serves as a similar function for the
band which means it's very easy to slide
the headset on and have it fit
comfortably the mixture of hard plastic
and cushions give the psvr to a
sturdiness and comfort that other
headsets relying on straps can't match
on the Quest 2 you need to pay extra for
the comfort by buying a headband once
the psvr2 headset is on it's easy to
make adjustments to find The Sweet Spot
that works for you a dial on the front
moves the spacing of the two internal
lenses so you can better align them with
your eyes while another on the back
tightens the band to secure it to your
head similar to how it worked with the
original setting up the psvr2 is a
breeze which is a far cry from the
original headset's mess-off cables
cameras and breakout boxes this time
around it's as simple as plugging a
single wire into the front of the PS5
each sense controller must be physically
plugged into the console via the USB
port but that's just once to pair them
from there the PS5 recognizes that a
psvr2 has been connected and runs the
software setup again the process is
streamlined to the point where it
requires almost no interaction from the
user Beyond advancing tutorial prompts
and informational text boxes since it
has Inside Out tracking via the four
cameras on the headset the psvr2 quickly
scans and Maps the room around you which
it visualizes in a core geometric pulse
and then defines a safe play Space
taking into account any nearby objects
naturally the optimal environment for
the psvr2 is one which has a clear open
space with the freedom to move around
without bumping into things it also
needs to be a well-lit space so that the
various cameras on the headset can keep
track of your movement most people won't
be able to play in perfect conditions
however in my case I stood between my
couch and a chair position behind a
coffee table which amounts to about a
foot of space and my lighting came from
the bay windows during the day and a
bulk standard light bulb at night
despite these less than optimal
conditions I didn't have many issues
while using the headset but after the
freedom of Quest 2 being Tethered to the
PlayStation 5 was a little Annoying
initially as it is also a limiting
factor on the range of movement you have
even with being able to quickly see my
surroundings I found that part of my
attention was always dedicated to making
sure I don't get too engrossed in the
game so as not to send my console
crashing To The Ground by yanking on the
wire but the trade-off is being able to
Leverage The Power of the PlayStation 5
which has a noticeable impact on how
ambitious games can be the only other
hiccup with my less than ideal
environment happened when the sense
controllers became inconsistent with
finger tracking resulting in strange and
unexpected movements in game this seemed
more pronounced in the evenings when
there was much less natural light it
wasn't a major problem at all it's just
a bit odd to see my virtual fingers
glitching out every now and then my
favorite feature on the psvr2 is a
little button on the underside of the
headset which pauses the game and swaps
the visuals to a view of the room you're
in so you can see your surroundings it's
not a crystal clear colored video feed
and is instead a weird night vision like
view but it's more than enough to safely
walk around the room and pick up or put
down controllers reorient yourself or as
I did check to see what level of bemuse
my cat was while watching me this is one
of those situations where the hardware
specifically the external cameras is
being smartly utilized to give the user
a better experience the whole process of
going from taking the psvr to out of the
box to playing a game takes just a few
minutes and what helps significantly is
the smooth integration into the
PlayStation ecosystem there's no need to
make new accounts or merge them as
you've probably got an existing
PlayStation account and it leverages
that as someone that went through the
ordeal of dealing with oculus accounts
Facebook requirements and migration to
matter this frictionless experience was
very much appreciated there's nothing
more to setting up the psvr than that
but where it gets complicated is the
games from the outset there's one clear
showpiece for the psvr2 that
distinguishes itself as the killer app
if you will Horizon call of the mountain
as I mentioned when I previewed the game
and the headset call of the mountain is
a reminder of how Transcendent a high
quality VR experience running on
powerful Hardware can be the technical
specifications for the headset are out
there if you want to know the
nitty-gritty of the internals but the
end result of all those bells and
whistles is that Horizon call of the
mountain is a beautiful game easily one
of the best looking VR games I've ever
seen and better still it makes effective
use of every feature the PlayStation VR2
has to some degree the OLED displays and
advanced technique such as fovea in
rendering deliver rich and vibrant
visuals that render the wall of horizon
with an overwhelming level of detail
without compromising performance psvr2
allows players to get intimate with
their environments and the Fidelity of
what you see he holds up under scrutiny
oars glide through the water trees Sway
in the wind light pierces through
outcroppings and Mountain sides are
rough and craggy being able to get up
close and personal with robotic
dinosaurs highlight some of the superb
work gorilla did with its creature
design and the same goes for fire Sprite
and its wool I previously described the
feeling of being in the world of horizon
as awe-inspiring and this sensation
holds true now too that is for me the
enduring magic of VR there's nothing
quite like the feeling of using the
sense controllers to carefully grasp
panholes to climb my way up the side of
a towering structure only to glance over
my shoulder and have the virtual world
momentarily override my sights and
senses to make me believe in the Peril
that awaited me should I take one wrong
step playing Horizon call of the
mountain makes psvr to sing and it's a
beautiful song but for as impressive as
it is eventually I couldn't help but
think about the VR experiences I had
when the technology and games first
became available and what they are now
and how little they've evolved for its
power are Horizon call of the mountain
developer fire Sprite has done an
exceptional job of taking the tried and
true gameplay ideas and mechanics that
VR has to offer and executing them
superbly in a triple a VR title call of
the mountain is virtual tourism in a
fantasy world at its most engrossing
it's one of the best climbing games I've
ever played the bow and arrow combat is
incredibly satisfying and the game even
has a story that fans of the Horizon
series will enjoy experiencing but at
the same time each of the components of
this game Exist Elsewhere in other
experiences for other devices and have
done them before many times that brings
me to the biggest challenge that psvr2
faces there's nothing that truly
distinguishes it from the competition
yes the headset is Cutting Edge and the
sense controllers with their finger
tracking capabilities are both capable
and comfortable even if they utilize in
predictable ways outside of very limited
cases mainly Half-Life Alex VR games
feel like they're trapped in the same
small box of possibilities they came in
when the rift hit the market all those
years ago there's nothing wrong with
these ideas just as there's nothing
wrong with taking existing games like
Gran Turismo or Resident Evil Village
and using a VR to open up new ways to
play them the question then becomes is
that enough for you and is that enough
if it's all it will ever be with a price
tag of 550 the cost of the PlayStation 5
it's attached to that's an important
question to ask yourself especially at
launch when psvr2 feels more like a
luxury item then a must-have gaming
platform for some spending that money to
have the latest technology is all the
justification they need but for those
that are interested in entering the
world of virtual reality in Earnest
psvr2 is a tough recommendation at the
moment as I said I enjoyed my time with
Horizon call of the mountain but no
other game made the same kind of
impression on me Kayak VR Mirage let me
paddle around a few Real World locations
during the day night and while a storm
was happening and although it was
definitely impressive to be in realistic
Recreations of locations I probably
won't visit in real life these Thrills
were are fleeting there's only so much
Furious paddling I want to do in my
leisure time cities VR let me create my
own Metropolitan Paradise by using the
sense controllers to effortlessly lay
roads erect buildings and micromanage
the day-to-day existence of my virtual
fiefdom but the process of constructing
what became my nightmare hellscape of a
city felt more novel than something I
want to return to over and over again
why I found myself missing was something
that Charmed me in the way that astrobot
did when I turned on my PS5 for the
first time or a game that showed me
something new and only possible in a
virtual reality video game experience
you might say that's a lot to ask of
PlayStation designers and developers to
create revolutionary ideas in VR but in
a crowded Market where other some
cheaper options exist that's exactly
what it needs to do if it wants to
separate itself from the pack it says a
lot that the games that I found myself
most enjoying were either old or
available in other places moss and Moss
Book 2 are utterly delightful and if
like me you let them pass you by the
first time you should Rectify that
mistake tentacular a game where you're a
kind-hearted monster with tentacles
trying to complete tasks to help out the
quirky citizens of La calma is funny and
creative it let me use the psvr2's
excellent eye tracking to interact with
characters and the sense control is to
pick up and fling objects for some
physics-based mischief and being in a
galaxy far far away in Star Wars Tales
from the Galaxy's Edge is a lot of fun
but these are all games available in
other places the hurdles at PlayStation
and psvr2 needs to overcome if the
platform is to have a fruitful future is
ensuring that there's support for it and
not only that but giving people a
compelling case to buy it or use it by
offering exclusive and unique
experiences as it stands Horizon call of
the mountain is carrying the psvr on its
back the lineup of games that support it
will grow and there are a few games on
the way that I'm eager to play Resident
Evil Village and Resident Evil 4 remakes
VR content Chief amongst them still I
can't recommend spending the cost of an
entire gaming console for them
especially not at launch this leaves PSV
VR2 in a strange spot as a successor it
improves on what came before in every
possible way it's a very well made VR
headset that has a high quality build
and premium feel while utilizing
powerful technology and features to
ensure it hits all the markers for what
a modern VR headset should offer and it
does this while being paired with an
equally powerful console capable of
rendering or inspiring virtual spaces
but there's nothing that makes it
absolutely essential to own right now
beyond the throes of being there on day
one for new gaming Hardware or if you
just really want more Horizon what Sony
has created is a VR headset that can
exist in the space between the
affordable but underpowered Quest 2 and
the expensive but powerful index but
much of what it offers can be found on
cheaper devices like the Quest 2 which
has the added benefit of being
Standalone and wireless for enthusiasts
and people willing to push through
motion sickness like me it's very
impressive Hardware that needs more
software to actually impress them I hope
that Sony and its Partners start
thinking outside of the box a bit more
when it comes to games and commit to
support enjoying the platform long term
in a meaningful way the excellent
Hardware deserves as much if they do the
future of psvr 2 will be exciting but
for now that excitement is built on the
same thing that VR has always enticed
hopefuls with potential
foreign
[Music]
could she really be here
waiting for me
Mary died of that damn disease three
years ago
in my Restless dreams
see that town
Silent Hill
I
know
I know why I needed you
[Music]
but it's all over now
I don't need you anymore
Mary
[Music]
that was that
[Applause]
[Music]
it is time to purge the Heretics
Unleash Your wrath upon the enemies of
the Imperium
plunge headlong into the Grim Dark
Universe of Warhammer forty thousand
who will prevail against the darkness
the ultramarines
for the emperor
only in death does to the end
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
let that you're out
this road
I will hold you
and protect you
you so let love
warn you
you tell them all
I'll stay
with you
by your side
close your tired and I'll wait
and soon
I'll see your smile
in a Dream Baby
[Music]
don't worry
it's okay
I'll always be with you
heart
party
[Music]
don't worry
it's okay
no one should have to suffer such loss
you know I meant it when I said I
understand how you feel but if you hold
on to the sadness it'll weigh you down
like an anchor
welcome meet my cruiser
foreign
[Music]
it wasn't the UCA that made the final
decision
it was a pack a private Corporation
so let love
warn you
until the morning
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
wisely
cars watch them fall blood on a marble
wall I like the way they
[Music]
[Applause]
do
Halloween dreams
[Music]
what we've done that set in stone the
past is forever but the future even if
it has been written can be changed so
focus on the future not the past
he wants to finish what he started
he wants to reclaim his Birthright
and rule over the planet with Genova at
his side
[Music]
I saw you lying there I figured it was
too late
wait what are you implying that I died
that I'm some kind of imposter
you are here with me
five years ago
where are you
what happened to you
I'm trying so hard to find you
sorry feel like I failed you
[Music]
imagine
foreign
[Music]
levels created by other users
Let's Dance
[Music]
available now
instead Has Fallen
it's great Army decimated by the legions
of a deer the demon god
but one light still flickers in the
ever-growing Gloom the light of the dark
crusader
all right
the radiance of monstered with us
[Music]
it is Darkness threatens to desolate our
world
Ascend to Aureus my child
as His Holy Redeemer
in light we walk in my
burn their very souls to Ash
[Music]
your flesh has been made sacrosanct with
the mark of the dark Crusaders
[Music]
great potential dwells within your
doubtless for you to be chosen thusly
and
[Music]
then
oh
prove yourself worthy of this gift
[Music]
by your Radiance grant me the strength
to continue to endure these dark days
[Music]
another unfortunate made a slave to
unceasing hunger
I pity you
reignite the Blessed beacons of monstada
and thwart ideas
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
one who could even beat me
is disappointment
will one of you finally give me what I
desire
yes
we will
[Music]
of the street
as well
[Music]
foreign
it is time
[Music]
to wake up
to a new reality
to a blank canvas that I have painted in
with warmth and peace
my new era
era choice is yours
whether to live in quiet serenity
or bloody strife
we dwell in joyous prosperity
or bitter rivalry
who can't face each other
as sworn enemies
or United as brothers
[Music]
but a storm is brewing
and soon you will discover
that even in this new era
[Music]
one constant remains
there is always something worth fighting
for
you have chosen to defy peace
then you have chosen war with a god
foreign
[Music]
we think there is an incredible
opportunity to make our platform games
and peripherals more accessible so that
even more people can enjoy the magic of
gaming we're just getting started with
our accessibility Journey with PS5 but
we're so excited about what we've been
able to do so far and our plans for the
future
[Music]
foreign
many of us have a personal story of
either knowing someone with a disability
or a family member with a disability and
wanting them to be able to participate
with the PS5 and so it was really us
coming together to
ask ourselves what could we do based on
all the input we received from the
community to be able to craft something
that really opened the doors
partnered with a lot of outside expert
consultants in this area charitable
organizations that help and advocate for
gamers with disabilities really helped
us understand what challenges we needed
to solve in order to provide a more
accessible controller that was more
Hello ever
okay let's talk about something else
outside probably not great
it's probably going to be a good time
today hi everyone we're prepped we are
ready we're very excited my name is Lucy
James and joining me is Michael Heim hey
what to do baby antonym hello boys
welcome summer game season has
officially kicked off uh Playstation
getting out of the gate that with the
summer showcase
prep to be a big one run time of over an
hour plenty of things uh on the horizon
what is a their official description is
focusing on PS5 and psvr 2 games in
development from Top studios around the
world expect a glimpse at several New
Creations from PlayStation Studios as
well as spellbinding games from our
third party partners and Indie creators
damn now PlayStation have been pretty
busy they had some kind of investical
type thing yesterday where they were
talking about the fact that psvr2 has
gotten off to a better start than psvr
one let's get psvr out of the way sure
um what are we expecting to see today
oh something at least games talking
about games that PS VR doubles
um so I I think uh most can say that
psvr2 while was a an oppressive piece of
technology I think there's uh there's a
hankering for more robust uh video game
experiences on the psvr too uh as for
what that can be who's to say I don't
have any Insider knowledge but I would
like to see at least something from
major Studios that they have internally
to make the most of the tech because it
is impressive stuff and like I said
they've sold well so uh they're it's not
like they're they're hurting for uh
pushing these things out so I think the
people who have invested in any of the
early adopters for this Tech I think you
want to at least throw them a bone or
get them excited about something because
uh yeah I mean they wouldn't put out a
new Cutting Edge VR platform without the
necessary support that's what that is I
mean everyone's talking about like
bringing Half-Life Alex to psvr to I
don't think that's gonna happen but
something on that level right
um it's been three years since we've
seen that game and I thought that you
know this is going to this sets the bar
so high that I can't wait to see what
other developers do so something at that
caliber at least one thing would be I
think would be great and necessary for
PSP or two astrobot yeah I mean like
like my I am said like it they really
need to justify having one of those
things right now I think I reviewed psvr
and uh
I'm pretty sure I did uh one of the
things I said was it's a fantastic bit
of Technology but currently there's
nothing on this system or this platform
that justifies having it that is
um distinct from everywhere else other
than Horizon which was
cool
um if you like motion sickness yeah if
you like motion sickness like me
um most other there he is ah you'll love
to see it most other kind of VR
experiences are available on other VR
platforms so we still haven't had a
there's not a collection of really
compelling games that are PlayStation VR
too focused which is something that's a
major piece of the puzzle currently
missing given that they just said we're
selling these things like hotcakes If
the previous hotcakes were the measure
um
uh warm cakes given that they've said
that they now have kind of teed
themselves up to make good on that
because if they're like oh we're selling
loads of these and then don't say
anything further it's like we're gonna
be like all right so you're robbing us
so yeah fingers crossed for some more VR
experiences and I do want what I am said
like I don't want versions of other
games like I don't need a new version of
Resident Evil in VR I mean that's too
bad which you might get yeah it's
definitely happening but like that's
fine but like I I think we're at a stage
now where Sony needs to start putting
this money where his mouth is and
showing off like this is only playable
on psvr this is a VR exclusive game
whether that from a cost perspective
makes sense
debatable but let's find out yep uh Tom
I wanted to talk to you about uh your
wardrobe today let's go baby
oh my God this man this man is
manifesting I am manifesting okay I need
metal gear in my life again I mean it's
always in my life as you can see but um
yeah Metal Gear is obviously the the big
one that people have been talking about
as a rumor yeah
so for folks at home who are maybe a
little unfamiliar we're talking about
the fact that there was a rumored Metal
Gear Solid 3 I'm looking at the camera
like I'm in the office a male gets Solid
3 remake coming to multiple platforms
and also uh some kind of classic
collection with MGS one two and three uh
because isn't it still unavailable to
buy yes oh my God yeah hold on they were
like Konami were like we're just gonna
take this off we're just gonna clear
some footage and it'll be back soon
absolute lies
that [__] is gone they said forever gone
it's like the only way you can get it
now is if you buy the physical version
which I did HD Collection which is good
but still it's like damn man you gotta
make that available for us again
um maybe we'll see that again soon I
would love to see that again but yeah
the rumor is has been for the longest
time that a remake is happening
for MGS one for MGS three three yes
that's the that's the one that I would
love to see an MDS the one remake yeah
um that's what I want to do like and you
know blue point is the natural kind of
um
recently bought into the PlayStation
family also has been Rumblings of them
making their first original game instead
of doing a remake and if that's the case
we the kind of metal gear thing it
either hinges on that being incorrect or
blue point being a team big enough to
have multiple projects projects
concurrently
um to some degree but I
Konami is in starting to make inroads
back into games in some ways where they
they've someone basically kicked a door
in and was like did you know you have
IPS like good ones you're trying to do
anything with that [__] no we got it we
got we got pachinko machines that's what
yeah and they were like we've got the
pachinko machines and they were like no
put that in the video games you can make
crazy if I want a Pachinko video game
yeah so now that nowadays it seems like
they've suddenly realized that they can
make games again and so we've got Silent
Hill happening there are Rumblings of
Castlevania there's been I mean there's
multiple projects multiple Sciences
projects and obviously Metal Gear is
their biggest franchise and Sony has
been going out there and throwing a lot
of money around and securing exclusives
the world a world where Sony walks up to
Konami and is like you're making a metal
gear we're gonna take care of the kind
of development side of it we're gonna
shoulder the burden you're gonna get
this massive bag of money you're gonna
like it it feels more and more like it's
it's there so what would you do if it
was a remake of Melissa
I'd be like I would stand there with a
megaphone and read my review out for
that game or I said it was like a
Abomination
um five out of ten on gamespot.com I
hate to see it yeah you hate to see it
but yeah I think like it would be a
massive thing for them
um and and if that shows up today it's
gonna be one of those Earth shaking yeah
absolutely I will be falling over myself
I mean twins uh twin Snakes whoa that's
when's the next remastered how about
that
uh Snake Eater that is uh that is the
goat that is my favorite uh one and
there's been multiple versions out there
playing on 3DS you're a real one uh but
you are yeah but that that's my favorite
I think that's the one uh that we've uh
I would say Fallen by the wayside but I
definitely want to see a new version of
that because uh that is for me is I feel
like one is is a good one to do because
it's got enough room for experience sure
yeah you know what I mean like three is
very very kind of like defined in a lot
of ways and I feel like if if they start
getting creative with three people get
more upset whereas one now that you kind
of right okay it's very short this isn't
very linear and a developer coming along
and being like we're going to push the
boundaries out on this a bit and make it
a little more open world I feel like
that's a safer bet than doing three
having said that I'll take anything at
this point yeah give me two answers
that's thirsty I want to see fat man in
Modern Day graphics hell yeah all right
one for you one for you rumors of a
Persona three oh my God people have been
talking about Persona 3 remake for quite
a while now and for me every time I see
that pop up I think it's fake and too
good to be true because Persona 3 means
it's not bloodborne PC
let's not go there but Persona 3 means a
lot to me and it means a lot to many
people and I you know if this if this is
true like I I don't know how much I can
how many eggs I can put in that basket
at this point but people keep saying I'm
prison three remake whatever it's gonna
be showing at this and you'll be showing
that thing but if it shows up today I
will go ape [__] I will go ham I will
I'm yeah I'm gonna lose my [__] man
because uh yeah I've thought about this
for a very long time just like first
time I played with someone three I'm
like man what would it be like if they
did this in the five Persona 5 style uh
like engine and art style or whatever
and so for for about five years now I
have been daydreaming just pacing around
my apartment pacing around the office
just imagining what a reveal trailer
would be like for Persona 3 remake and
one crying to myself be like what if we
hear burn my dread again with like the
same voice actors but with better
graphics a fully realized world and it's
kind of like what that's the Persona
game that kind of kicked off its style
of Social Links and like Tam said about
MGS like mgs1 that's the one that has
like the most room for growth
Improvement yeah if we were to bring
this into the modern world there's a lot
that they can do with modernizing that
and uh taking the like all the great
things that it did as a classic but just
bringing that into a modern sense would
really highlight what made that game so
special so uh if yeah like I said if we
if we see it today which I would not bet
on uh but we do
the dungeons in that game are probably
like the easiest thing you look at let's
go like we can we can make this better
um so yeah that's my favorite one
because it's hip-hop aligned so I'm I'm
Lotus juice
bring them bring them back bring them
back uh do we think we're also gonna see
uh Last of Us
Finns revealed uh officially at summer
game first 2022
obviously naughty dog have quite the
spring in their step after the success
of the HBO TV show
um or do we possibly think you know
there was that live from PS5 sort of AD
trailer and there was a sort of
character who's blonde could have been
Cassie Drake kind of doing a little
adventure thing do we think we're seeing
stuff from Naughty Dog today I think
well I think the thing was I can't
remember where we landed with Uncharted
being given well they said it was like
done yeah well the rumor was like they
were handing off the franchise to
another studio right but then there was
also I can't remember if I'm making this
up but there also was like some Whispers
like oh they took it back and they're
like if anyone's gonna touch our baby
it's going to be us as I said naughty
dog to me does not seem like the kind of
Studio who would relinquish control of
something yeah maybe what if if somebody
were like we are making an Uncharted and
you're gonna do it well the only time
they did it was Blue Point with them
yeah uh golden Legacy yes Abyss Golden
Abyss
Golden Abyss yeah and listen that wasn't
particularly good yeah but yeah I I
think I think uh factions is more likely
than a new Uncharted
um factions has been
just eagerly anticipated for so long and
they've shown nothing of it I feel like
they could also get away with just
showing just a slight look at it like
just an older it's a snippet yeah yeah
and that would that would also align
with what Jim Ryan's been saying about
them trying to push live service games
yeah uh so I feel like that would be
that would be a good thing to put in
front as like this is our first push
into our our multi-year plan to put out
live service games you know like said
last of us has so much momentum and that
multiplayer like if you play it back in
the PS3 days that multiplayer had
something to it uh so seeing a more
fully realized version a standalone
version of that can be very exciting I
am kind of iffy on live service games
today as we've seen many uh many like
shut down many great games just don't
get the support that they need but you
know Sony would not let the Last of Us
die out uh so you know that if they're
going to put this out it's going to be
fully supported uh all the way through
so uh but yeah I think now would be a
good time to show up because it has been
a while since we last heard about the
state of actions so that would be kind
of exciting it might be about Royale
onto an Island full of
infected I wouldn't I wouldn't put it
past one
um all right time elephant in the room
oh you want to talk about there's the
elephant it's in the room is it
bloodborne time
oh baby let's go it is not happening
even even the uh so Lance McDonald if
you're unfamiliar uh YouTuber who uh has
unveiled a lot of cut content from
bloodborne posted in his Discord the
other day that he's seen uh a new build
or something running on PC obviously I
mean the games games are built with
pieces
I can get Tetris and Mario running on
PCS these things are coming to PC
um how much how much stock you putting
in this time I again like I'm I'm a
known bloodborne like
um and I would say that was such a shame
like no uh it's just the elephant in the
room and the most obvious thing in the
room I would love for that to happen
um I think
it kind of depends on it's similar to
The Naughty Dog situation right I wonder
if from uh the kind of Studio who would
relinquish the project to someone else
they did it once with demon cells but
demon cells is a very different type of
profile than bloodborne right I wonder
if they would be like we want to be
involved and that's the scuttlebutt I
believe like it's like that if it
happens they want to be involved and
right now they are busy with a little
game called Elden ring
um so I would love for it to happen more
than anything I think a PC release is
more likely than a remake
um sure that feels like they can just be
like hey you don't have to be involved
in this we're just going to make it run
on PC run well and that's it same game
don't worry about it yeah and I would
love for that happen just because it
makes it easier to get into but also
um yeah I don't know I don't know how
much
Sony wants to invest in this and it's
got to happen at some point because that
game is just like it's a classic it's a
classic and the thing is like I don't
think they expected it to be a classic
when they released it back in the day I
think it was another one of those where
like maybe this will get a small group
of people and then it absolutely popped
off and since then they've been very
reticent to kind of engage with the IP
on a very public level mostly because
people will absolutely lose their [__]
and if they even say the word buddy
though man like uh that's like the most
curious thing to me is that uh maybe
it's just because we're in some kind of
circle or bubble that just absolutely
loves bloodborne we all do and like it
feels like one of those situations where
from software has like a break in case
of emergency type thing yeah like if
Sony has it Northside okay software yeah
we've got loads of these don't worry
about it yeah they got bangers on Deck
you're like we're good we don't need
bloodborne anymore but I maybe Sony
looking at that like
um breaking case of emergency because I
feel like that's that's a layup for like
a bloodborne remastered just like upres
with better frame rate I imagine we
instead get like a demon soul style
remake of Dark Souls
that came out of nowhere like I feel
like we don't need that though yeah we
oh I don't know recently I mean yeah it
runs well on Modern consoles but it
still feels like it feels like Dark
Souls it's like from back in the day
that is the kind of thing where it's
like if Blue Point were like hey we made
that banging demon Stars remake we're
gonna do the same thing for Dark Souls
please be excited I think a lot of the
people who are dying for a blood bones
also be like we'll take it
we've got about 10 minutes until they
started station so showcase so those are
the big big rumors uh let's go into what
we're probably gonna see today so
obviously not long until the launch of
Final Fantasy 16.
uh obviously kind of uh in the middle of
a big PR push uh for it you know Michael
you just played Four play the first four
hours in addition to two hours of like a
save deeper into the game which I did in
February and then just a couple weeks
ago I got to play the opening four hours
which you can uh see my my thoughts on
gamespot.com my full written preview or
watch the video that me and Jean Luke
worked on which is a wonderful video
that I outline how I feel about that
game uh it's very story heavy in the
that's kind of the thing you know folks
want to go in without any expectations
about the story
me watch my video maybe muted
but uh yeah 16 is coming out next month
maybe they show off a new trailer
they've been yeah I feel like I wouldn't
say they've been saturated with uh
trailers for this game I don't think it
hurts to put out another one but they'll
probably be like hey don't forget 16 is
coming out soon it's not like that do
you remember that year E3 where Kingdom
Hearts 3 was on every oh yeah oh yeah
yeah
trailer had another second oh yeah the
one trailer they played and like half
the sound effects didn't work oh yeah
there's like hey we got we got another
chance run it back run it back uh but
yeah I think uh 16 is coming out soon
kind of we know what what that is just
waiting to it's the year of Clive let's
go I don't I don't know I don't know
about that I'll have to play 50 more
hours of that game to see if that's true
but uh but the other Final Fantasy I was
gonna say so we go Final Fantasy 7
rebirth AKA finals Fantasy 7 remake part
two uh do we anticipate seeing that one
today
I don't know because I don't think they
would want to overlap with if they show
a little bit more 16 I mean they're in
the middle of it I don't know if they
want to overlap I mean they've done it
before I guess so like once the the
faucet is open they're like get all the
final fantasies out yeah but now Kyoshi
is probably on that board saying like
listen give me my space y'all seven
rebirth is probably going to be a slam
dunk for those who love seven so he's
like yo yo boxing everyone out it's like
this is my time this is my time uh but I
wouldn't complain if we saw some more uh
seven rebirth because that's winter 2023
last time we heard which I would predict
to be the very beginning of next year
um so they still have time before that
is out but hey man if I I'm curious I've
replayed seven recently and I have a ton
of questions about how they're going to
fit that that piece of the story Into
the framework of the Remake I think also
like if this is as it seems to be
indicated Sony's big thing for the
summer like their Big Show and that game
being an exclusive it would warrant it
being out bit even though Square Enix
has its own thing going on later on down
the line I think that's where they are a
little more like we want to stick to the
Final Fantasy game the new Mainline game
and we're gonna put the focus on that
maybe they have like a follow-up
addendum to anything that they showed
today in which case then is more
feasible that Sony will be like hey
here's another look at Final Fantasy see
more at Square Enix showcase next month
or whatever it is because it behooves
them to do that if this is their major
like E3 or sgf yeah
um game awards is also I like to play
with words
[Laughter]
two or three years acquisition rumors
about the fact that my PlayStation go by
Square Enix what are we what do we
reckon that ain't happening I don't know
they've shed a lot of they've shed a lot
of uh bloat I don't know I think that
would have been more likely when they
were bloated and like kind of not
hitting now that they I feel like Square
Enix is like we're back baby they're
good we're popping we've got final
fantasies yeah we've got and like most
of their non-japan stuff is like very
thin right like they don't have a lot of
Investments outside of it I mean
Crystal's not theirs anymore right uh
yeah Lego across a little IO a long time
I was gone yeah that feels like the
majors are out of the picture so like
they are refocusing on us right Montreal
yeah
it feels like they've like doubled down
and refocused on the stuff that they
know are guaranteed hits which is Final
Fantasy and Dragon Quest
um and then in between that they're like
have you heard of octopath traveler
octopath travel to the current game of
the year uh how's about these nfts oh
God if I I would be surprised if they
mentioned okay
oh my God I would I would be extremely
pissed if that was the case that ain't
gonna happen though I don't think
I don't think we as greatness ever
mentions ever again nfts in a public
like showcase style setting again
they'll stick it in like investor
relationships
yeah no one's watching yeah
all right so we also have uh I guess the
big thing that everyone is anticipating
seeing today is going to be
Marvel Spider-Man 2 Spider-Man the
Spiderman there's two of them two of
them but it is uh as and somebody I
confirmed it a while ago and it kind of
hit the news again because they tweeted
it out they just tweeted it out that it
is going to be a single play game no
Co-op no online multiplayer even though
there are the two Spider-Man in it uh
what do we what do we think to know do
we think we're gonna get a gameplay
that's coming out this year right that's
I think we got to see it if the Venom
voice actors to be believed uh it's not
uh Tom Hardy right no no unfortunately
just tweeted out a while ago damn well I
mean I think Now's the Time if it's
coming out this year this fall I imagine
yeah it'd be a good time to show exactly
what that is because yeah that's kind of
what they did with the first Spider-Man
they showed it during uh during either
E3 showcase came out
um they came out and followed that scene
okay yeah yeah
um yeah probably no puddles what's the
power of the PS5 your puddles are going
to be Exquisite
um yeah I feel like that's the Marquee
game for this year so it would it's an
imperative they have to show they show
that stuff today I think that's a given
a certainty The X Factor
it's not really they're not X-Men are
they
um the the X Factor potentially is
wherever actually at The X Factor is
wherever Wolverine shows up yeah yeah
um because that's the obviously the next
thing and next major thing that
Insomniac is doing and I feel like if
you wanna
really have the uh Playstation showcase
be the center of the conversation for a
few days you show off a decent amount of
Wolverine and um Spider-Man and you're
like damn Insomniac are killing it so I
think I think there's a decent chance
that shows up Spider-Man definitely
Wolverine maybe maybe okay I really hope
to see Wolverine yeah
what else do we think uh we've only got
a couple minutes uh so what are your
your picks uh what are your what are
your hopes and dreams I would like to
see maybe something from Death stranding
too I don't know that's kind of uh I
don't know if we're gonna if we're
necessarily uh gearing up for that game
quite yet maybe I don't I'm not sure how
far along it is but you know a little
Norman Reedus a little uh Leia is that
how you say your name yeah French name
you know a little bit of that in there I
would be I would be very happy with that
but uh otherwise I just want to be
surprised oh yeah Kojima was tweeting uh
or posting from
um yeah I think uh death stranding two
was my the other thing that I was
wondering whether it shows up but there
are obviously a bunch of potential other
games that I could show up like Diablo
is imminent so maybe that pops up maybe
this is a final push for Street Fighter
um but that's coming up soon oh yeah
it's probably going to be an advert for
Destiny at some point I do hope that
they have I mean like I was gonna say I
hope they have like a really like
Megaton but between Metal Gear
I think Metal Gear would probably be
that but if not I would love for them to
have like another Megaton to kind of
like push the conversation forward and
Sony are generally quite good at that
they take the known quantities and the
stuff that is heavily rumored and then
always drop one cherry on top for people
to just
suckle on for the next year hey yo
you know what I'm saying oh
so I mean for me I am most excited to
see Final Fantasy 16 that's going to be
my whole personality for the rest of the
year oh sure okay sorry no I would love
to see one of the new projects from
Bungie I know they've been kind of
working on a few things in the back
burner
um one thing I was gonna say the any
cream any Credence any uh thing from the
the mobile streaming device
yeah yesterday Jim Ryan said they have
some fairly interesting and quite
aggressive plans to accelerate our
initiatives in the space of the cloud I
think that shows up our CES instead of
one of these things like I feel like
those kind of announcements I hope that
these companies have really got it in
their head now that they are 100 moment
Killers yeah this might be not be the
Right audience
like don't like it puts a dampener on it
but that
blockchain and nfts and Cloud stuff it's
automatically yeah
like mobile game that they've made is
going to be coming out in 2023. oh so
highly likely we could see there's
rumors as well the Bungie have been
working on getting Destiny playable on
mobile
okay sure
um with that Atlas
um uh RPG that isn't Persona wait a
project refantasy where the where the
hell is that yo it's been six years
what's going on hashino
damn it's like I've been on vacation all
right I mean I've been busy uh so we are
going to be watching along the uh the
Showcase uh silently so we will be back
after uh the Showcase so make sure you
don't go anywhere boys we've got about
50 seconds
let's go Metal Gear oh show clarity get
ready let's go Metal Gear manifesting
with my jacket and my hat and my
underwear if the well if there is
Persona if there's anything Persona
related make sure you're back for the
Post show because I will cry on stream
if there's any
day everybody we'll see you after the
show
foreign
[Music]
you want to know about us
seems like everyone does these days
it's simple
too much money and too much power is
held by just a few people
and it's only getting worse
so
we decided to do something about it
let's go
[Music]
don't come out till June is my pick I
prop you said my I dudes got a window
seat like Erykah Badu
[Music]
you ain't got it then you can't flaunt
it pull up Lamborghini
[Music]
hi everyone
I'm Jim Ryan president and CEO of Sony
interactive entertainment
I'm delighted to be here today to
introduce what's next for PlayStation 5.
we're now into the third year of the
life cycle of PS5 and we've been
fortunate to have so many fan favorite
titles released on the platform what's
even more exciting is the developers are
just scratching the surface of what's
possible with the gaming experiences
that they create today you'll get a
glimpse into some of the most
breathtaking and imaginative content
that will be coming to PS5 and
Playstation VR2 and now what you've all
been waiting for
enjoy the show
[Music]
super Earth
our home
our way of life but Freedom doesn't come
free
look familiar
scenes like these are happening all over
the Galaxy right now and you could be
next that is unless you make the most
important decision of your life
prove to yourself that you have the
strength and the courage to be free
join the hell divers
[Music]
experience true Freedom requesting air
support
the freedom to travel the Galaxy
and secure the resources we need to
build a better tomorrow
the freedom to encounter fascinating
life forms and introduce them to our
sophisticated technology
the freedom to make new friends
and represent the best gift of what
super Earth has to offer
become part of an Elite peacekeeping
Force and work together to spread
prosperity
Liberty and democracy
become part of something larger than
yourself
become a hero
become a legend become a helldiver
becoming a held ever may result in
decapitation or morbid occasion not all
he'll never survive
[Music]
sir
it's the hand
follow but do not engage
maybe engage a little
night blades have established a
stronghold and kirken seems to think you
might not get me killed
jury's still out on that one
[Music]
oh [__]
oh boy
roshanians haven't had enough yet we
haven't given them enough yet
[Music]
shut up
your men killed my family
don't turn your back on me
[Music]
foreign
what's your plan
knowing you have only 66 Days to Live
[Music]
just run away
I won't make any difference at the end
of the day
[Music]
you know better than anyone else
that no one could
us
everyone wears a mask you too this is a
real face
you let you live what secret did you
sell them
second
oh and where this damn place you're
suicidal
[Music]
thank you
one last toast
and we're all done
foreign
[Music]
yes
let's kill him with time
[Music]
what's your plan
knowing you have only 66 Days to Live
[Music]
get my heart back
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
a new world awaits you full of dangers
and Mysteries
signs and wonders things that I in my
garden could never have imagined
[Applause]
[Music]
think of the world we could build if we
believed in ourselves
if we truly believed in what it means to
be sentient
to face the universe without fear or
delusion
imagine vast cities full of life and
life
great Towers Rising Towards the Sky
so much would be possible
[Music]
if we believed if we still have faith
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
laughs
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
ready for the foam Star Party
[Music]
welcome to the land of Mojo here we find
John the Plucky Squire and his friends
Violet thrash and Pitman Our Heroes
protect the land from the villainous
sorcerer hungrum
pay adventure to the edges of their
realm and even
[Music]
Beyond
their jot finds a whole new world to
explore with dangers surprises and
attractively furnished accommodation
our heroes must battle hum rump across
the two Realms if they are to save their
beloved land from his diabolical designs
off the page and into Adventure
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
what a thrill
with darkness and silence through the
night
[Music]
I'm searching and I'll melt into you
what a fear in my heart
thank you
because
[Music]
thank you
a blind marches on
these people live with a knife to their
throat you have to believe us we'd help
you if we could
you're helping us already
we never asked to be saved did you think
we'd thank you they'll never forgive us
we're all marked now
every time you show your faces it is we
who suffer
you better hope so
crystals take more than they give you
need to tell me that the mother crystals
of the reason the world is dying
to how we're talking if they won't give
us a say we'll decide our Fates another
way
for what you've done
why aren't you dead
Tell Me True do you believe what I'm
about to do is one I was forced to kill
you do it by choice
believe in me they believe in the power
of the dominant you Can't Blame A man
for wanting to bring it into all this
can you ever let us Stray by your blind
result and thus is
we don't need your salvation we'll save
ourselves and we'll do it on our own
terms
who are we what are the dominance we are
but Mighty acts of God enough of this I
use my talents to my advantage you will
tell me there is shame in that
we shared a dream I would be the king of
the world
hope it has made you forget yourself I
don't want to be a monster of life
I made a promise to my friends and it is
they who will give me the strength to
end your Reign your efforts will Avail
us not
the fight we survive we enjoy we don't
need a reason
[Music]
foreign
I write to escape
every word is a step forward
Into Darkness
I'm glad you're on this case with me
Anderson
it's right up your alley
the victim was one of their own
FBI special agent Robert Nightingale
so you knew our victim only the rumors
he was chasing a writer
someone knew they were here was playing
a game with them
killer left the message
it's for us
the text is about us
we were all trapped in a horror story
The Horror Story wanted us dead
there's something I forget it
it's something important
something's not right
easy now
first things first what's your name
welcome hidden one
[Music]
you have died and been Reborn
we need to find a way to get you inside
without being seen
you could bribe the guards to look the
other way I shall see what flavor best
suits me
[Music]
embrace the fear
quiet it find the Stillness
let's go
foreign
we will be watching
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
monster
come back
Let's Fall
away
[Music]
let's heat it up it's time
I've crossed paths with many during my
journey for True strength
I've also met my share of enemies
opponents I had to overcome
my journey knows no end I will continue
to do what I have always done
when you said you were seeking strength
despite having no real need to do so
honestly I thought you were a complete
idiot
[Music]
Masters he was set up
I'm not nearly strong enough to chase
out your monster like that
[Music]
it's probably worth looking into this
nice shawl business
[Music]
es
he attempted to set the world under his
field through violence a veritable
Madness
when you go looking for strength
not like a game
this journey doesn't have a reality
[Music]
fighter sick
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
forgotten that you've protected me from
the dragon's flames you need only
believe in your own destiny
force that begs the question if he's a
man Mama then where might our true and
recently than personating his life is in
your hands sir praise be for only the
sovereign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back for another week of career
fulfillment and minimal social
interaction
we know how challenging it can be to
find a place where you feel that you
truly belong and to find a job that
treats you mostly with respect and only
infrequently with contempt
for that reason we are excited to inform
you that you did an adequate enough job
the first time around to have you back
also there were no other applicants
so strap yourself in and get motivated
to an appropriate degree
because you ain't seen nothing yet
[Music]
thank you
how far could he have gone
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
forgive me Father
[Music]
like a lot
you see everything started two years ago
when I met Fred
and ever since then it's like I see his
face everywhere and lately I've started
to develop some destructive tendencies
what do we have here bro what's a bit of
armless fun hello uglies
[Music]
and since I met my new best friend I
guess I get a little overprotective
yeah
okay very overprotected
I'd love to sit here all day and chew
your ear off I'll be right out boy
but as you know
time waits for no man
catch you later
[Music]
who's a good boy
looks like today is going to be a
scorcher
[Music]
okay
foreign
ER Conrad he was one of ours before he
went rogue
we intercepted com's chatter referring
to neurosynaptic Tech that they've gone
dark
I don't have to remind you what's at
stake here we need that Intel by any
means necessary
it's connected to a mind synchronization
device this is Cutting Edge
interrogation Tech we're out of time and
out of options we've got to go in
[Music]
another land to the slaughter
welcome on then
let's see what you're made of
[Applause]
impressive I'll admit
I need you to focus the clock is ticking
you have to adapt
back again
pathetic your heroics mean nothing
you're getting close you're approaching
the center of your subconscious you
think you're a threat
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you've missed so much
we're flame gods
Vanquish nightmares
spot alongside those who we once fought
against
me too kiddo
but hey I'm here now
wherever the hell here is
[Music]
contract site coming up
15 seconds
[__]
10 seconds
[Music]
five four
three three
gutters here we go
[Music]
foreign
the best Gran Turismo players in the
world will compete for a place in racing
history
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
thank you for joining us today
before we get into our final game
I have a few announcements to share a
PlayStation Innovation is our passion
and that applies to not just what games
you play but how you play them later
this year we will launch a dedicated
device that enables you to stream any
game from your PS5 console using remote
play over Wi-Fi internally known as
project Q it has an 8-inch HD screen and
all of the buttons and features of the
Dual sense wireless controller
we look forward to sharing more
information in the near future I'm also
pleased to reveal our first ever
PlayStation earbuds which will bring
Next Generation audio immersion to PS5
and PC they simultaneously connect to
smartphones via Bluetooth new wireless
technology will deliver lossless audio
with low latency giving you outstanding
sound quality while you're playing
look out for more details soon we hope
today showcase demonstrates our
continued commitment to delivering
experiences that surprise and Delight
our players I want to thank all of you
for your unwavering support for
PlayStation
[Applause]
thank you
you grow slow in your old age circuit
a fate you will not share
I've been in your Shadow for hours but
but since nothing
pathetic
I asked for an equal
and this is what you find
sir
perhaps
a new hunting ground
[Music]
[Applause]
light the fires
the great hunt begins
[Music]
this is cited in Queens closing in now
cover the door
the Beast could be anywhere
oh
yeah
Grayson wants a hunt I'll give him one
he'll never forget
he's gonna wish he never came to New
York
stand by and make quarters
Frederick scanning all activities
triangulating position
Target located at Harlem Fish Market all
teams converge lizards across the river
I'm not gonna make it in time
[Music]
miles the hunters track Connors to the
Harlem fish market
dessert
I'm on it sounds like Craven's checking
off his we don't have much time move
uh guess we'll chat later
Genki the lizard's loose at the fish
market must be Sushi night you still got
the hunter drone you hijacked and really
tough hiding it from my mom but yeah
I'll boot up and see you there
they got here fast
[Music]
can't let them find Connors what he's
done for
[Music]
thank you
spread out if you find the lizard don't
engage alone
look at those fish it's been feeding
we ever saw it coming
[Music]
so how's the hunt going
foreign
ers
garage might lead to him
Connor's tore through this place
[Music]
troll
s
foreign
where am I now
how'd you find me the fish
drones picking up lizards trails
he's still eating
catch him off guard
Yankee get behind me
it's just his skin
doesn't that mean he's getting bigger
hungrier too
man
new threats the building's swarming with
Hunters any sign of Connors uh yeah
genki's tracking him hey Mr Parker
I mean
but the date isn't complete
that wasn't me me neither
I don't even have a stomach so
let's go
thank you
go go go make him alive
can't lose counters Harry's dying and
he's the only one who can help we won't
you take the Drone I got the jet skis
well if I borrow this
this is really really exciting keep it
tight man watch out for those drones
don't worry they think I'm a friendly
thank you
take him out
East River is not a river but in fact a
saltwater title flash but Spider-Man is
fighting on right now
help the tour boat right I've got the
metal murder bird
I warned you about going after Connors
now this is on you
the poison clouds is that all you got
almost done here civilians are all safe
how you looking
this gunship won't quit I'm right behind
you we'll take it down together no time
to go boom boys no no no Spider-Man it's
good defenses
Spider-Man hang on
[Music]
let's go
it's right behind you I know I know whoa
eat faster fly faster
I do not want to be Liverpool
got him hold on
what are you guys doing trying to take
out that gunship can't get close enough
but I can't I'm one of them remember bro
that's it hey alley-oop on three hi
one two three Ally
he got away from us
it's good Pete
I saved the tracker
let's go man before he gets too far no
it's mine
you sure
it's got big teeth
so do I
[Music]
do I um he's not normally like that
right
no
he's never like that
[Applause]
[Music]
was it to be a trick of the senses
it's time
all right
morning
[Music]
[Applause]
to attention
[Music]
[Applause]
yet
[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to the Game
Spot post show for the PlayStation
what's it the PlayStation summer
showcase no it's called the Metro Solid
3 reveal event that's what it's called
all that rest of that [__] don't matter
okay I blanked out all of it my eardrums
burst at that moment because of these
two and John Luke but uh I'm Lisa James
uh joining me again Michael hayam hey
let's go and tomorrow Hussein hello all
right let's talk about it melchia solid
three and the uh one two three
collection Master collection yes volume
one
which means there are other volumes on
the way yes sir
um interesting obviously Metal Gear
Solid we saw CGI Cuts in the looks of it
um we didn't get any information on
who's developing it nope
um so that remains a mystery we did get
confirmation that it's although it's at
the PlayStation showcase is coming to
steam and Xbox series X and S I think
um so it is popping up everywhere what
are you doing he's doing the the
triangle doing the triangle Metal Gear
Solid triangle strategy the rock throw
your diamonds in the sky if you know the
vibes
um yeah so I it I mean finally it's out
there finally yeah after many many years
of uh Whispers and rumors and
speculation is finally out there the
question is does it look as good as the
Pachinko oh wow yeah yeah
um I think it probably does yeah yeah my
man my man looks thick my man looks
sweaty
um the other question I have is will our
Our Man David hater be reprising his
role as naked snake
yeah it was in the other game with with
Jennifer Hale so Naomi and snake are
together currently so yeah let's get
them in uh yeah we get unless we get the
24 star Kiefer Sutherland no the the
thing I'm now thinking about is like
when do we get to see their game again
surely sure like is it coming up at
Summer Games Fest you know Jeff is all
over there there's no way Jeff is
letting that one slide
well I mean we're gonna get him looking
up at a screen picture but it's going to
be green
well no we've got summer game first we
have Gamescom uh I assume there's gonna
be like another PlayStation showcase
later on in the year on holiday season
so maybe the
yeah we didn't get a release window or
we didn't see gameplay we just know that
it's actually a thing now so it's
probably gonna be a long while since
until we get some more solid information
on this game but I mean you can correct
his naked snake thank you
who who who who who uh who screwed that
up not me do you because you said more
solid information ah [__] y'all but uh
but yeah I mean like I said in the in
the pre-show Snake Eater is my favorite
I still think it's uh it's the best
metal gear and I want to see what they
can do with a new version of that that's
gonna be sick
I mean every Metal Gear is the best
metal gear okay sure you know what I'm
saying for different reasons yeah uh but
yeah that collection though is uh I'm
hyped about that collection because
finally it's unplayable in some in like
in illegal forms I mean there's many
illicit ways to be playing the metal
gear games but yeah volume one I want to
see Peace Walker portable Ops acid like
yeah let's go ooh if they if they're
going to that extent to bring back Metal
Gear just just go all the way that would
be sick okay ghost Babble remake oh my
God who's asking for that is that a
visual me I am asking for it all right
now ghost Bible is the Game Boy game I
believe it is one of the best metal
gears
that was one they were talking about in
the besties recently wasn't it um yes
yeah yes didn't sound that good wow wow
wow uh
so yeah it's obviously big metal gear
announcement
um I think the other thing that got us
the most hyped in this room because
let's start with the hits
that Allen wig 2 trailer yeah
that was just like one thing after the
other dude
that was that [__] was hot uh Kurt and
Novena our fellow co-workers
host of Squirt Locker uh he's I mean
he's uh he's at the dentist right now
yeah he [__] up his teeth uh getting
so hyped for the trailer that he uh well
the trailer fell over and ruined his
teeth oh but on the side of the table I
mean Allen wake 2 is was one of our most
anticipated games already but the
trailer that they showed for this
showcase is it levels they're
exponentially more hype for this with
the you know we got we got to see
gameplay and the re reveal of one uh Sam
Lake in the video game yo I cannot wait
to give some like character of the Year
oh my God
yeah I mean we here we were we were
talking about in the office last week
about you know if they could bring back
Max Payne we want to bring back Max
Payne One version of Max Payne with Sam
leaks Sam like stank face but yeah in
full HD all that on on PS5 on Next
Generation but uh but yeah y'all were
talking about how you know I mean it
looks like Max Payne it's connected to
the Max Payne universe but there's
layers to this right yeah so it's like
we've been talking about this for a
while like one of our resin experts Mark
and has been theorizing for a long time
so I've been discussing stuff but that's
probably not Max Payne it's Alex Casey
who is the character in Alan wake's
novels who is based on Max Payne yeah so
they could very easily thread this all
together into one Universe because a
remedy connected Universe because
there's also the implication previously
that control is a product of Alan wake's
imagination or his creativity because
his and bright Falls is in yeah
yeah so they are they are doing the
connections well here they're making it
work yeah remedy it feels like remedy is
one of the few Studios who are doing
some just like wild [__] with their
their games and their their ideas and
just like the way they string them
together kind of like not not whoa oh
you got a meeting of you
you want to go somewhere else you're in
that meeting
uh but yeah the Alan Wake too even more
hype for that was that was a really
really good thing to show if you would
like to learn more about Alan Wake too
please come back to Gamespot tomorrow
where we will have something for you to
read
anywhere else can we say that let's be
excited I think we can yeah we're
leaking Alan weeks uh next week we're
teasing something but yeah yeah come
back tomorrow
please be excited what do you call Ellen
wake fans like Alan heads Allen Hive
Alan Walkers oh God
uh showcase kicked off uh so there's
obviously so many games to talk about
we're probably just going to talk about
the uh the big uh the big hitters and
the ones that we we like the most uh
fair games the new uh one from Haven
studio uh headed up by Jade Raymond
formerly uh of the Assassin's Creed team
um and uh Google stadium for a minute
yeah a little bit
uh so yeah it looked I don't know a
little bit
Watch Dogs yeah meets payday yeah it
looks it looks like it's a multiplayer
Heist uh thing that got going on I mean
maybe it's part of that live service
push that we mentioned in the pre-show
that Jim Ryan was talking about
um but you know it's got that colorful
art style it reminds me of like X
defiant from Ubisoft oh yeah so it kind
of falls into that that you know that
weird and wacky colorful
um kind of irreverent style of tone that
uh we're going for I think we saw like
multiple games go for that and we would
talk about foam foam City foam party
from Square Enix like oh there's a lot
of that like a reverent colorful uh Vibe
going on with a lot of these multiplayer
games so I mean I'm not gonna no I'm not
gonna say that I'm hyped for them but
you know foam pie what was it called
what foam City foam Stars foam stars
there you go
four foam hub
is not no it has something else
basically
um yeah so that was that was nice if
they had me in that game where there's
like welcome to the film Hub
you can connect with your friends here
uh one game I do want to talk about
because we were watching it and uh it
was you tweeted I think Tim it's the
most team ninja ass game it's not made
by team ninja Phantom Blade zero uh from
s game which is the studio behind the
2021 mobile PC game Phantom Blade
executioners which I've never heard of
but a Soul's fun
number one I weren't doing anything for
me yeah that looks like a more closer to
like a Ninja Gaiden Style game sure yeah
than anything else it looks like they
went that girl's good let's do something
let's try that um just came out which is
you know very kind of kind of sick
um I think yeah it looks it looks fun It
looks interesting I mean I don't think
that was gameplay a little bit so um I'm
intrigued by it but I don't think it's
it's going to slot into the uh the souls
born yeah it seems like they're going
for something else yeah definitely yeah
um I do I think the the interesting the
the stack between you know sci-fi with
all the machinery and Technology that's
in there but also kind of like the that
that old school like uh Ronin era style
that they're kind of clashing between I
think there's something interesting
there but uh I don't know I will keep an
eye out for that one uh moving us on uh
to sword of the sea which uh the well
it's the game from the artist behind
absu the pathless and journey yeah I'd
love to tell them a lot like not to be
productive but a lot of Jamie
I mean there was the entire sequence
where there's the sun in the background
skating on the dunes and I was like oh I
see what you're doing there yeah we we
was all saying oh that's that's Journey
too like like we already figured it out
but
um but yeah that's uh I don't seems cool
I really like what uh like the the thing
about those games is like the the the
art style the aesthetic also plays into
what the those games are about so uh
that is one uh that I am going to keep
an eye on as well uh and there was a
bunch of like really cool looking
public holiday
never playing that wow that's no that
that [__] looks sick cycled that joke by
the way you said that while we were
watching uh I will probably play that I
I I like you I don't know too very
emotional there's a there was a big
there was a big baby wolf and then it
died and then there was a widow baby
wolf with a really long neck yeah
um that uh why are you getting
self-conscious huh Tom made a joke we
were watching John was like who's you
it's a Lucy wolf uh but no there were a
lot of cute looking kind of indie games
so we had uh Cat Quest pirates of the
third yes uh the Plucky Squire looks
really yeah what was the um
the one where it looked like the will of
Talos film herb
that was Tyler's principle too yeah what
was one where it was
oh um Revenant Hill yeah which is which
is is basically a sequel right uh
Island wake trailer yeah sorry not in
the woods yeah and I was I was watching
but uh I think uh I mean I haven't
looked up any information after the
trailer but it looks like it's something
separate because there's like actual
humans in that world and the cat does
look like me but it's like an actual cat
cat but it's the same same art style uh
I think Scott Benson uh is that that
style there is uh it's very striking
it's it's unmistakably you know what's
the the logo for this thing looks like
yeah it looks like the same aesthetic as
Night in the Woods uh so fingy I'm oh
I'm I'm hyped for that that's like one
of those you know Night in the Woods has
really got me in my heart the fought for
that thing and Game of the Year debates
2017. I remember that didn't win though
it did not shy in the woods damn I hate
to see it what did win 2017 yeah 2017.
that Indie darling
so uh we had Assassin's Creed Mirage
another look at that yeah yeah it's nice
yeah nice to see again yeah another
smaller scale Assassin's Creed is is
something that I'm very interested in
and it definitely looks like they are
reigning it in a bit because
yeah yeah got too big yeah got too big I
wanted to play Assassin's Creed games
without feeling immediately exhausted as
well yeah and this feels like they are
definitely and also they're going back
to a setting that I'm more interested in
and some of the recent ones you know so
it's another thing because I really love
the setting of Valhalla like I love uh
England that sounds weird uh oh wow
surprise Hometown English person loves
England extra extra Read All About It
oh I mean when I was like
I was like well that's my [__] uh no but
you know like I really like the um uh
the Vikings I found that really
interesting
um watch Finland Saga it's very good
went to Iceland recently too Iceland
Iceland Iceland stock market no and so
and the thing is I was always really
disappointed not disappointed with uh
Mahala I was just like okay this game's
too big I thought you pulled up to
Iceland like where are all the Vikings
I'm very disappointed Reykjavik is not
popping like that
really yeah [__] I need to go have you
seen that damn
oh [__] anyway uh so I'm really excited
about Mirage I'm looking for something a
little bit more manageable because I
think a problem with more Mainline
Assassin's Creed games recently is that
it's just full of bloat absolutely just
not nothing is really compelling me to
continue playing or driving me forward
so yeah and this one does look like it's
um like it feels like it at least looked
like it plays like a fully current gen
game rather than you know doing cross
generation and you know so it looks like
there's at least a step up in the tech
and how it flows in place so I want to
see if they like untangle the story a
bit as well with the whole
because uh for
the lost game well how I kind of wrapped
it up to a degree I think sure Jordan
about this and he was explaining the
story and I was like man
I don't care anymore at least are they
still going after the apple of Eden or
do they already eat that [__] I think
they
unless it's a spoiler I think Desmond is
back yo my boy Des I think he's he's
like
that that might be that might be wrong
but like I don't know Jordan was talking
to me about it and you know when like
you just hit me
that's whatever you were talking about
for you
sorry Jordan we love you yeah um we just
haven't kept up with Assassin's Creed
for the past 50
. um I did until it got stupid
um and convoluted but uh We've also got
Dragon's Dogma too
unfortunately this was the point in the
Showcase where I did have to have a p
because I drank uh too much Diet Coke so
boys fill me in what was what I miss I
mean it looked like a Dragon's Dogma ask
dragon's dog in my game yeah which is
great I mean like I think after the
T-shirt reveal like yeah this is a good
Next Step but it feels very similar to
or looks very similar to what you would
imagine a a modern Dragon's Dogma game
looks like I'm interested to see what
more gameplay stuff just because of you
know the original being so focused on
like climbing and having the pawn system
and that kind of Pawn
oh about to say yeah the awn okay
p-a-w-n not the pornography system
although you could probably find that as
well if you want
um but yeah I want to see more of the
intricacies around that I would love
them to you I would love for them to use
the pawn system again because it was
quite
um revolutionary you know yeah and uh
p-a-w-n-hub yeah
uh yeah this is where you can collect
your pawns it's called PornHub I don't
need anyone to know about that oh no
Dragon's Dogma too it felt like it was
very or dragon dragon song One felt very
forward thinking uh so for two I would
expect as much or at least because it
was a pretty rough game it was a rough
around
it was a little it was charmingly yes
yeah so yeah yeah uh so in terms of the
so FNAF
hmm
helpline too uh re full remaking VR I
mean the cool thing about that is you
have to actually
the knife Perry you have to do it
yourself with your hands I'm not
spamming L1 I don't want to know about
it yo chainsaw's coming at me yo I'm
gonna be Untouchable in the real world
I'm just like oh oh [__] I'm gonna keep
that knife on me don't come after me
I'll pair you
we also had Arizona Sunshine two uh
Crossfire Sierra Squad
because everyone really loved Crossfire
and Crossfire X yeah well fans well I
mean it's back yeah
I think it'd be our form yeah overall
like the VR stuff synapse from end
dreams that was David hater Jennifer
Halo on the thing that got me was the
beat saver yes I'm not a big fan of
Queen I just like beats a robot oh you
you're so private English but you hate
Queen wow damn well she's dead no I mean
the massive Ellen died
I don't I don't mind Queen but if I want
if I want a beat saber pack I won
personally Nine Inch Nails I want you
know Hall and Oats Muse
I don't know that's what British people
like right
Muse yeah is that is that y'all no
offended are they a bridge they are a
bridge okay okay
um Gary Newman Peck I'll be good that
would be really good uh but anyways back
I mean some Bops Britney pack Mystique
pack
David David cage David
cagepack [__] Craig David Craig David
patch let's go beat saber get me a Craig
David pass hell yeah I'm in
um another couple of other surprises was
was Marathon yes uh Michael tell us
about it so marathon is an OG bungee
joint pretty Halo that was a Mac game it
was kind of I was talking to Jean-Luc
earlier because he's a little bit more
familiar but that game was also a
Forward Thinking With You know how it
tells a story and how it builds out its
world and kind of a sort of prototype
for the first Halo that we got so the
bringing it back Bungie is now under the
under PlayStation's Banner is bringing
back the IP Marathon but word on the
street is is that it is a very different
game from what that original Marathon
was right
yeah and uh again I keep bringing it up
but it feels like that's also part of
the PlayStation live service push if
this is a PVP game and extraction style
seems like that's you know this seems
like that that kind of game is going to
fall under the games as a service
structure yeah again this is just me
like spitballing ideas of what it could
be but yeah Tam mentioned it and I was
like ah my enthusiasm keep a real child
like my enthusiasm enthusiasm enthusiasm
for kind of
I dipped a little when I found out that
information but you know what I mean
like an extract extraction issue is all
the flavor of the month right now
they're all the rage sure
um and bungee making extraction shooter
could be interesting given that their
pedigree when it comes to shooting that
feels good yeah
um so I'm more interested in that
extraction issue and then probably any
of the other extraction Shooters out
there just
between them being like basically
impenetrable right now and being generic
as hell yeah I think what actually well
John Luke was getting more hyped about
was the the Bungie uh reveal for the new
they and now at the Showcase they
announced the new showcase yeah Destiny
showcase and Nathan Fillion
it's Evan
yeah
it's K-8 now
oh they already brought back Kade one
time right
how many times has been revived by the
Dragon Balls who knows what the [__] who
knows uh but yeah there's more Destiny
on the way and this I I think it's going
to be like their their end Walker moment
where they have uh they're kind of gonna
wrap everything uh wrap everything up
okay six is just typed all caps cage six
I know that he's k-6 but I'm making the
joke yeah because he's coming back now
that's the joke that he was making yeah
come on now well uh and then finally to
top off the Showcase we had uh
Spider-Man two Marvel Spider-Man 2 so no
sadly no Wolverine which I'm sad about
uh I would have loved to have seen Logan
him my sweet boy but uh we got it I
don't know a pretty uh meaty look at
Marvel Spider-Man 2
I'm not gonna lie so I liked it felt
like I saw a lot and I was saying to you
guys as we were watching I was like
an action scene this long would be fun
and intense to play but to watch with
very little context yeah especially when
you're getting to groups with new
characters new powers
um clearly a lot of story stuff that's
happening too I was just a bit like yep
yep yeah the the uh the main thing was a
kind of swapping mechanic that looked
cool which is cool okay um we don't know
the extent of it it's like can you swap
at any point or is it pretty determined
kind of moments where it's like peonies
are hand switch over to Miles
um or is it full GTA 5 yeah I doubt it's
full GTA 5. the other thing I'm
intrigued about is
and I trust Insomniac to do it well but
we've had the Venom story told so many
times now like I'm slightly concerned by
that but also they played uh they did
like rework or took a new spin on the
original Spider-Man story so I trust
them for the first game I trust them to
kind of put a new angle on it I just
hope it's not the same like oh no p is
being corrupted by uh the Symbiote I
guess I'll look that way I guess miles
wasn't around for that phase of Peter
Parker in in the comics but maybe
there's some Universe where it's there
is that story but I don't think I've
read it or seen it but that is a kind of
New Angle but yeah that's interesting
but like you said we didn't see a lot of
kind of moment-to-moment gameplay we got
to see a very extended cut scene and
everything the combat sequence yeah the
combat sequence was good
um but like you said I I kind of want to
be wanted to be playing it instead of
watching it yeah but I think that's a
testament too yeah because we all know
how nicely the game can go sure yeah I
mean it's more of a known quantity than
some of the other things that we saw
because we played two of these games at
this point miles got a squirrel suit now
he's got his oh yeah oh you can
basically fly so Insomniac is making the
Superman game that no no one else is
getting yeah so that's I'm excited to be
uh playing Miles Morales again so yeah
I'm hyped for that but yeah it's uh you
know it's it's those action sequences
that you've seen in the Uncharted style
that uh QuickTime events and things like
that
uh all right to round uh out our post
show then what your final thoughts what
were your highlights boys Metal Gear
Solid Delta
it's the Rock
throw your rocks in the sky I don't know
what we're doing
um so for me uh I do want to shout out
the uh Grandview fantasy relink what
that's my game of the show baby
um
maybe I think oh well no that was Tower
of fantasy he was like oh what is this
anime [__] I'm going to the bathroom
uh no grandma fantasy relink it's been a
long time since we heard any or since I
heard anything about that game so I do
appreciate the grand blue universe and
it's cool to see that it's like an
action RPG uh from side game so I mean I
don't have like super high expectations
but you know it's nice to see that it is
being shown and it is going to be out
there uh and also the the project Q the
Q the the streaming thing not that I'm
hyped about it but I was like oh okay
they actually showed it before uh
Spider-Man 2 Timothy Ryan was just like
hey let's talk let's
earbuds and let's talk about this
streaming tablet that we're gonna sell
for y'all so
um I think I think that show that part
of it was
done well because it was very brief yeah
they were like this is the thing that
we're making see you later here's
Spider-Man and then they can elaborate
on that and like in their own time on
you know separately or as CS or
something like that it's a good move on
that important part for that yeah other
than that foam hub let's go foam hub
is it cool no it's called phone City
foam Stars I see foam stars that game
what was the what was the marketing line
for it it was like get pretty get foamed
up
uh uh gold foam yeah go how to go foam
maybe join the phone blasting frenzy no
that was it no join the phone I've seen
that before I mean like oh God if
everyone just made the immediate like
read on it which is like oh so you like
Splatoon did you good stuff
um we got Splat and now we got foam so
yeah but you'll highlights yeah Metal
Gear Delta
um and the other Metal Gear came coming
back or being available again
that makes sense because Konami once
charged for Metal Gear again make it
make sense yeah um but I will I will
sadly as you can tell I will happily pay
for metal game multiple times
um so that being so the Remake happening
finally good I want to know who's making
that game and what is the extent of the
Remake
um I also want to know what does the
volume one of the master collection
entail and what does that mean for
future volumes
um and are they going to put the
original games back on Marketplace and
Playstation
um or are they just gonna download those
entirely and just have these ones take
the Rockstar if it's if you take the
original I wouldn't trust Konami to I
mean I feel like Konami has a track
record of not necessarily caring about
like preservation of their old stuff so
unless it's bomber man hey my highlight
was Alan Wake too yeah oh my God can't
wait I mean I I was also very
Okay so Allen head Allen Hive rise up
all right sure uh so no I mean only two
I think that trailer was fantastic I'm
so excited to hear more so again
your eyes appealed to Game Spot I'm
looking at the wrong camera kill me
um
there we are uh I'm also really excited
about Final Fantasy but right I feel at
this point I've seen I I was I was on
board that with that game with the first
trailer yeah oh yeah yeah and so I've
actually I [__] cried on a stream
with y'all
been a Mainland Final Fantasy that I
haven't played yet so I'm not about to
start now so uh and I'm also so sorry I
haven't read your preview yet because
again I mean like I said you know just
watch watch give us the give us the
watch time minutes give me the page
views you had to read it so yeah
um but yeah that's coming soon I'm
excited for that as well yeah the year
of Clive is upon us the year
white dude names Clive damn Allen I hate
to see it Steve Max
Steve from David
oh bring him back
I don't know what it is I'm gonna wrap
this up thank you again for watching uh
we are gonna be on the ground in La for
summer game Fest uh we're gonna be
streaming from the 8th till the 12th I
believe it is
um so I was gonna be very excited please
join us for all the awesome coverage
Hands-On interviews that you can handle
you can find me on Twitter at least
James games you find me at Michael B
High I'm on Twitter and I'm Timor h
uh rise up Alan heads join the phone
phone
me up yeah zaddy
leave it there thanks for watching